arrivé au dernier chapitre camp quand tu
te rends compte que tout ça c'est
complètement métaphysique
là je vous jure j'ai senti opta bouger
mais vraiment pas juste un petit frisson
je les ai sentis bougé et je me suis dit
il a compris en fait il a compris la
nouvelle
c'est un truc ça m'étonne pas la
littérature c'est tellement deep les
miens mais attends moi d'haptonomie
m'ont pas dit du tout frein j'aime alex
émond beat pendant une heure et j'ai
même pas senti le bébé bouge pas quoi
mais je savais pas qu'il fallait faire
des trucs rue cela comment tu dis qu'il
s'appelle le mec gogol que non mais non
d'accord par nicolaï gogol corail celui
qui a écrit le nid beaucoup geogeo à
elle j'ai vu le tir du gauche mais siens
et pas de problème et ça peut passer par
autre chose n'était pas obligée à longwy
ouhlala épatant tu peux dire tu peux ça
peut passer par de la musique
ouais je vois ces mêmes par des images
indécis dessin animé même tu partages un
petit dessin animé ce qui compte c'est
vraiment que tu partages quelque chose
avec des bêtas que ça sympa tu lui
parles de temps en temps tu lis pas oui
ou carrément ouais parce que là
franchement si tu si tu crées pas le
lien maintenant après du communiquera
plus jamais avec lui tu avoues bon gp
bonjour chaque être est détruit comme
nous cessons de le voir puis son
apparition suivante est une création
nouvelle différente de celle qui l'a
immédiatement précédé sinon de toute
capitaine capitaine bien content de
rentrer au bercail
ce sont de magnifiques vacances à mon
brave milou et nos remise intelligente
pour les maps et il a pris ses
responsabilités sur penalty et de gros
efforts pour revenir défendre avec un
pressing de tous les instants géré ou
deux allô allô voix ressemble en ce
moment ouais bof ce fizir n est même pas
dit qu'il est déjà en train de vivre
gogol et puis le nautile y réagit à rien
quoi j'ai l'impression qu'il veut pas
communiquer avec moi du tout je me sens
nul en fait c'est le fils du raid mais
c'est pas la question
[Musique]
attends attends le bébé bazille boulga
attendant breton qui réagit à la musique
[Musique]
ça lui va bien
pas tendre avec moi je devrai bien tu
puises tu m'étonnes
[Musique]
les mains emma debout
je n'aime pas la baby shower
non non mais tu inquiéter juste que j'ai
j'essaie de faire la teuf pour faire
bouger le bébé mais ça va pas marcher
seul consistant que attend que attend
hier bouge là c'est à voir en fait ben
qui fait plus maintenant mais c'est pas
la musique test un way test 2 oui c'est
ça attendant il y avait pied à l'automne
[Musique]